ahora que ya sabemos un poco de
trigonometría por qué no tratamos de
aplicarla a la resolución de algún
problema digamos que tenemos la
siguiente situación supongamos que
tenemos un barco que tiene que ir de un
punto a a un punto b vamos a decir algo
así entonces aquí tengo el punto a es
este extremo
y aquí tengo el punto b en este otro
extremo y el problema nos dice que la
distancia entre estos dos puntos es de
10 km 10 km
muy bien entonces supongamos que el
barco tiene que recorrer esta distancia
pero el navegador por cualquier razón
supongamos que por ejemplo hay una
corriente que está en un río y hay una
corriente que va hacia esa dirección
entonces el navegante después de cinco
kilómetros el capitán del barco se da
cuenta que se salió de curso y que ahora
está por acá de hecho nos dicen más nos
dicen también que bueno esto vale cinco
kilómetros porque el navegante el
capitán del barco recorrió cinco
kilómetros antes de darse cuenta que se
había desviado en un ángulo de 15 grados
vamos a suponer que este ángulo de aquí
vale 15 grados
ok entonces lo que nos pide el problema
es encontrar digamos vamos a poner aquí
a nuestro pequeño barquito
y ésta está un poco feo pero ese es el
barquito está ahora en este punto lo que
nos pregunta el capitán es qué distancia
tiene que recorrer para llegar al punto
b es decir cuánto vale esta distancia de
aquí y pues bueno yo creo que involucra
trigonometría vamos a ver qué pasa
bien el modo en el que yo generalmente
resuelva los problemas de trigonometría
es tratando de escribir todas las cosas
que pueda y jugar un poco con los datos
y ver si llego' algo útil
generalmente así funcionan los problemas
entonces bien lo primero que voy a hacer
es dejar caer aquí una perpendicular
digamos una altura por este vértice
perpendicular a esta base para tener de
este modo aquí un ángulo recto tengo
aquí ahora dos triángulos rectángulos y
entonces ahora puede utilizar
trigonometría digamos podría averiguar
más bien les pregunto pueden averiguar
cuánto vale esta instancia de aquí este
lado que acabo de repintar de naranja
esta instancia que sería x este vértice
a este piedra de altura pues porque no
probamos con un poco de trigonometría
déjenme anoto nuestro zocato a eso
se no es igual a cateto puesto entre
hipotenusa que cose no es igual a cateto
adyacente entre hipotenusa y toda
tangente es igual a cateto puesto entre
cateto adyacente así que perfecto aquí
tengo este ángulo conozco esto este tipo
ten uso de este triángulo rectángulo
vale 5 y este ángulo vale 15 así que qué
función trigonométricas podría usar pues
el coche no me involucra el cateto
adyacente que sería estado este valor de
x y me involucra la hipotenusa así que
yo sé que el coseno él coseno de 15
grados cuánto vale pues vale cateto
adyacente que es x
/ hipotenusa que es 5 de modo que se
multiplicó todo por 5 obtengo que x es
igual a 5 veces el coseno de 15 grados
muy bien vamos progresando ahora que hay
de esta altura puedo averiguar cuánto
vale esto si digamos digo que vale y
entonces cuánto valdría allí pues ya
y es el cateto opuesto es el cateto
opuesto a mi ángulo de 15 grados así que
puede usar el seno y de un modo
completamente análogo podría decir que
es igual a 5 veces el seno de 15 grados
porque pues simplemente por la misma
razón el seno de 15 grados
no podría escribir como cateto opuesto
que sería james
/ hipotenusa que vale 5 así que
multiplicado por 5 y obtengo estos de
acá muy bien
ok pues ahora qué pasa si trata de
averiguar cuánto vale esta longitud
estoy aquí digamos z es lo que le sobra
o lo que más bien lo que le falta a x
para llegar a los 10 kilómetros que hay
entre a y b y de hecho si se fijan esto
es algo muy bueno porque si ya conozco
ya que de hecho ya conozco ayer lleva el
5 por el seno de 15 grados
entonces como este es un triángulo
rectángulo aquí simplemente tendría que
aplicar pitágoras el tema de pitágoras
para poder encontrar esta longitud la
longitud de tipo t nusa que sería la
solución a mi problema pero vamos por
partes primero encontrar ser yo sé como
les decía que z es lo que le falta x
para llegar a 10 kilómetros o dicho de
otro modo z es igual a 10
- x ok x maceta me daban los 10
kilómetros que hay entre el punto y el
punto b
así que 7 es igual a 10 - x pero cuánto
vale x pues equivale a cinco veces el
coste no al 15 grados de modo que z vale
menos cinco veces el coseno
a 15 grados
ok
esto ya se ve muy esperanzador
entonces cuánto vale esta longitud pues
digamos déjenme le pongo de de distancia
cuál es la distancia entre mil barquito
y el punto b pues como decíamos este es
un triángulo rectángulo el triángulo
barquito este punto el vértice b es un
triángulo rectángulo de modo que de
cuadrada me lo anotó por acá de cuadrada
va a ser igual a vamos a usar los mismos
colores de cuadrada más
más
z cuadrada
pero cuánto vale de cuadrada pues
llévale 5 por el seno de 15 grados así
que esto es lo mismo que
5 por el seno de 15 grados
todo esto al cuadrado más z al cuadrado
pero cuánto vale z pues se está vale
diez menos cinco veces el coseno de
quince grados
así que más diez menos cinco veces el
coseno de quince grados y todo esto al
cuadrado así que bueno si tuvieran una
calculadora aquí ya podrían simplemente
es meter esto en su calculadora y ver
cuánto les da pero como yo no tengo una
calculadora
vamos a seguir expandiendo y ver qué
obtenemos déjenme uso otro color
5 por el seno de 15 grados al cuadrado
cuánto sería pues eso simplemente sería
25 por el seno al cuadrado de 15 grados
más esta expresión al cuadrado esto lo
puedo tratar como un binomio al cuadrado
así que sería el cuadrado el primer
término que sería 10 al cuadrado que
sería 100 más dos veces el primero por
el segundo 10 x menos 5 sería menos 50
por 2 sería menos 100
y no debemos olvidarnos de este coseno
de 15 grados
más y ya no me cabe aquí pero voy a
escribirlo aquí a bajito más el cuadrado
del segundo término que sería 5 coseno
de 15 grados al cuadrado es decir 25 por
el coseno al cuadrado de 15 grados bien
voy a dejar este vídeo aquí los invito a
tratar de reducir esta expresión por su
propia cuenta pero vemos la solución
completa en la siguiente parte del vídeo